today's episode is sponsored by blinka
Stu the app that lets you read or listen
to an entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes you can try blink it's totally
free and get 25% off a subscription when
you go to blink ascom slash david pakman
I put the link right below this video so
Joe Biden recently put out his climate
change plan and clean energy plan and he
gave really a pretty solid speech about
it and I think it's important to cover
this stuff because number one Trump's
not really doing policy and I do think
it's important to draw a contrast when
one candidate is calling an urgent press
conference at the White House and
spending 52 minutes I believe it was
sort of erratically miss reading attacks
on Joe Biden from a piece of paper
whereas Joe Biden is actually doing
policy now I know that some people in my
audience are going to be furious with me
how dare I say that Joe Biden's climate
change proposal is pretty good it's not
the green new deal it's not Bernie's
plan it's not a o'seas plan or whatever
the case may be you know what let's
analyze it critically and understand
what have been the climate change
policies of people who have been
presidents and by that standard this is
the most progressive climate change
proposal that if Biden is elected would
ever be associated with a sitting
president of course you can find people
who have run who have had other
proposals which we might like better and
I'm including myself in that list but if
Biden gets elected this would be the
climate change proposal most to the left
of any previous president and that's I
think a really important thing to keep
in mind so we're taking a break from the
nonsense and the insults and the
hyperbole and the bragging of Donald
Trump and I need to do a better job of
when Joe Biden talks about policy and
puts out proposals I should talk about
it last time I did this I went into some
detail about Joe Biden's tax plan it's
pretty solid it does a number of
important things that progressives
should be happy about
despite Biden's reputation has not be
particularly progressive and so I'm not
gonna redo the whole tax plan story but
Joe Biden's tax plan includes a number
of important provisions like removing
the cap on Social Security tax above
400,000 a year in earnings that raises a
huge amount of money from people earning
above four hundred thousand dollars a
year Biden would propose or proposes
eliminating the stepped-up basis
provision for inheritances I explained
that last time I mean this is really
significant stuff in terms of the money
it would raise
I won't redo the entire tax segment but
needless to say many in the audience
appreciated it some just came in and
said it's not as progressive as what
Bernie wanted okay let's now look at Joe
Biden's proposal on environmental
justice and climate change and clean
energy now off the bat there's a bunch
of sort of regular regulatory stuff in
the proposal which I'm not going to
spend a lot of time on but it does bear
mentioning which includes Biden would
establish an environmental climate
justice division in the Department of
Justice Biden would make environmental
justice a priority within the federal
government Biden would refresh the way
that and sort of rehash the way that the
EPA does compliance that stuff deserves
attention but I want to look at some of
the specific metrics and actions that
Joe Biden is included in his plan so for
example Joe Biden includes specific
water quality improvements just to pick
one thing that's in his climate plan and
if you look at this part of the plan
Biden actually discusses and addresses
specific chemicals that are too much in
our drinking water and he does it in a
way where he seized water not only as an
environmental issue which it is but also
as an economic issue which it is he sees
water as an issue of social justice as
well so I think we should all be pleased
that Joe Biden is talking about water
quality in his environmental proposal in
a way that shows understanding of how
water relates to race class geography
economics etc etc
remember Joe Biden said that he would
use the green New Deal as a framework in
thinking about what he wants to do and
you can identify many things in his
climate change and clean energy
proposals that are almost verbatim from
the green New Deal now what's hilarious
is when Biden put this out and people
identified look this is like straight
out of Bernie's plan this is straight
out of green New Deal there were people
who previously were criticizing Biden
for not being progressive enough who now
are saying oh look Biden copied stuff
from Bernie and the green New Deal
shouldn't we be glad to see Biden
adopting things from Bernie Sanders and
from the green you deal like if the
concern was that Biden wasn't taking the
green New Deal seriously enough
shouldn't we be glad to see elements of
the green new deal in Biden's proposal
and you can see these components in a
few different areas when you look at
Biden's plan for retrofitting buildings
and schools in a way that will be good
for the environment but economically
stimulative that's straight out of the
green New Deal
a lot of the other things Biden includes
in these proposals are pretty obvious
things but there are things that aren't
being done or at least not done enough
like for example more seriously putting
in place subsidies and rebates when
Americans upgrade to more efficient
sources of energy and better windows and
efficient appliances that's worthwhile
government spending now two days ago
Donald Trump attacked Joe Biden for
having an ambitious goal in his proposal
and the the goal is Biden wants to be
carbon to carbon pollution free
electricity by 2035 meaning by 2035
Biden wants the country to be generating
electricity from sources that do not
pollute from the standpoint of carbon
that's a huge task but if the criticism
here is that Biden is too ambitious on
climate and clean energy I'll take it I
mean look at the Trump administration
that's going in the opposite direction
wanting to loosen emission standards for
vehicles wanting to rehabilitate coal
we've had that for three and a half
years I'll take
an overly ambitious proposal from Joe
Biden any day and importantly one of the
things I like about this proposal again
is Joe Biden is connecting energy issues
to economics and social justice and race
and he's connecting environmental issues
to all of those same areas so for
example when Biden talks about his
proposal that by 2035 he wants to be
generating generating electricity from
sources that don't pollute from the
standpoint of carbon he specifically
says let's do this by creating jobs with
this green energy shift where we will
look to HBCUs historically black
colleges and universities for training
and hiring etc just one example so where
I'm ending up on this is if you know
something about Joe Biden you actually
shouldn't be surprised that his climate
and energy proposal is very solid Joe
Biden actually wrote the first climate
change mitigation bill in 1987 he tried
it in 86 and it went nowhere in 87 it
was signed into law by President Ronald
Reagan and it's particularly
disappointing to see some leftists who
are framing Joe Biden as kind of like
reluctantly dealing with climate change
sort of Biden actually has been on this
for more than 30 years there's lots of
areas where Biden has not really been
great unless you look at the last 10
years if you look 25 years ago there's
areas where Biden was not so good
Biden's been on climate for more than 30
years he said he would use the green New
Deal as a framework for his proposal and
he did so let's criticize Biden where
it's warranted let's criticize Biden
where the proposals he makes don't go
far enough and I'll be digging into that
in more detail probably next week but
you know the pretending that Biden is
just a center-right guy on every issue
including climate it's wrong and the
fact that Biden put out this proposal
reinforces the importance of trying to
take the Senate so that we can maybe
actually get some of these things on Joe
Biden's desk put him in a position to
have to sign stuff into law rather than
having this long list of proposals that
will never see the light of day because
Democrats don't control the Senate
anyway so for me it's reinforcing hey
Biden's actually been pretty good on
climate for a long time and number two
importantly the importance of the Senate
to actually get some of this stuff in
front of Joe Biden to sign so we have a
panicked situation happening though but
Joe Biden's putting out proposals which
we've already talked about on the other
side Donald Trump has replaced this
campaign manager Brad bar scale with
only three and a half months to go in
the campaign now Donald Trump is framing
this as this is great I'm doing this
because it's just also wonderful
I'm gonna show you in a moment how
Donald Trump is presenting this change
but make no mistake don't be confused
you only replace your campaign manager
three and a half months before the
election if you're panicking and things
are going terribly and I'll actually
give you an example in a moment of the
last time a sitting president replaced
their campaign manager three and a half
months before the election now to back
up a little bit
rumors have been swirling about Donald
Trump being furious with his campaign
manager Brad Parr scale for a while I
think it was about two months ago when
the polling started to go south for
Trump there were leaks from the White
House that on a Friday night Donald
Trump was in the Oval Office on the
phone with Brad Parr scale screaming at
him and I'm paraphrasing here saying how
the F am I losing to Joe Biden and it's
been downhill from there both in terms
of the virus and Trump's polling and now
Brad Parr scale is out formally they're
calling this just a reorganization as
usual Trump is trying to put a positive
spin on everything he does tweeting last
night around 9:00 p.m. that quote I am
pleased to announce that Bill Stepien
has been promoted to the role of Trump
campaign manager Brad parse Cal who has
been with me for a very long time and
has let our tremendous digital and data
strategies will remain in that role
while being a senior adviser to the
campaign both were heavily involved in
our historic 2016 win and I look forward
to having a big and very important
second win together this one should be a
lot easier as our poll numbers are
rising fast that's not true the economy
is getting better vaccines and
therapeutics will soon be on the way and
Americans want safe streets and
communities so let me interpret for you
Trump realizes straight up firing his
campaign manager would look very
bad so instead he says hey we're just
gonna shift things around Brett par
scale is not gonna be campaign manager
anymore but it'll keep doing digital
stuff because he's so good there but
we're putting in place a different
campaign manager but everything's great
and everything's hunky-dory this is a
firing and your file at firing someone
who has failed but you're finding a way
to do it that maybe doesn't look as
panicked and the reality is Trump should
be panicked because his approval is down
a 36% in the latest Quinnipiac poll
we'll talk about that later 1000
coronavirus deaths in the United States
yesterday for the first time since June
9th so it's been five weeks since the
u.s. had a thousand coronavirus deaths
in a day we had it yesterday it's tragic
other countries have figured it out this
is unnecessary loss of life and the new
poll out yesterday shows that 62% of
Americans believe that Donald Trump is
actually hurting the coronavirus
response rather than being a force for
good when it comes to the coronavirus
response our friend bill scher pointed
out to me on Twitter this morning that
the last time a sitting president I know
that in 2016 in the summer Trump changed
campaign managers but and now I'm
talking about the last time a sitting
president who was running for
re-election replace their campaign
manager this late in the game was in
1992 when George HW Bush Bush 41
replaced his campaign manager in the
summer we know how that turned out
Bush 41 lost to Bill Clinton just a few
months later and importantly we also
haven't had an incumbent president who
was this far behind in the polls three
and a half months before an election
since 1992
either now in terms of the actual staff
change and the strategy here from Donald
Trump I don't know what parse scales
replacement bill Stepien
is going to be able to do right now
remember that Stepien was the guy fired
by former New Jersey Governor Chris
Christie in that entire Bridgegate
debacle that's a different story but if
Stepien was too incompetent for chris
Christie I don't know how he helps
Donald Trump Stepien is good friends
with Jared Kushner there's speculation
that that's really what what this is
maybe about hilarious
remember that Trump claims that all of
the polls that have him losing our fake
suppression polls and he actually
tweeted he's going up in the polls if
that's the case if you believe you're
winning why would you take out of power
your campaign manager who has you
winning it's because Trump knows that
he's in trouble
and I actually don't think that Brad
parce qu'elle is the problem I don't
think parse scale is a particularly good
campaign manager he is a good data an
analytics guy but the problem is not
strategy here the problem is that Trump
has failed on coronavirus and everything
else that has gone on and again the
easiest way to win this election for
Trump would have been in January in
February to start properly handling
coronavirus from the beginning it
literally takes months to get outbreaks
under control time is running out right
we're in mid-july and Texas is peaking
Florida's by mean peaking they're going
up they may not even have peaked yet it
takes eight to ten weeks to flatten the
cases and then an additional 20 days to
flatten deaths we're at election day
right understand that the timeline is if
all these states did everything
perfectly starting today we are at
election day before the numbers really
get under control and so all Trump has
left his dirty tricks
remember that understand that let me
know where you are on this I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman we had I know I told
you this last week and I told you this
the date of the week before and the week
before yesterday Wednesday was the best
day ever for the David Pakman show
YouTube channel and the David Pakman
show audio podcast you go back to the
beginning of the show yesterday was the
best day on both of those platforms and
just a reminder if you like consuming
the show in a longer form format get the
audio podcast for free on stitcher
Google Play iTunes Pandora Spotify etc
etc wherever you prefer we'll take a
quick break and be back after this
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
what if you could read ten books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinka stand what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down into text or
audio that you can consume in 15 minutes
blinka snakes sure that you're getting
all of the important core insights from
each book so it's perfect for exploring
a book you otherwise wouldn't have time
for there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blankets to get
a sample first just think how much you
can enrich yourself by being able to
soak up an entire non-fiction book in
just 15 minutes I recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
Stephen Hawking this is a book that I
have been aware of for so long and other
things got in the way and it was
fantastic to check it out on blinkin
blink east has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different nonfiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25%
off a subscription when you go to blink
east comm slash David Pakman I've put
the link right underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com today's new members of the
day are madeleine de vida and Matthew
Fisher thanks to both of you for
supporting the david pakman show through
membership also a big THANK YOU to
Julianne Ross Julianne is today's
longtime sustaining member of the day
who has been with us almost five years
grab yourselves a membership at join
pakman.com get the daily bonus show
whether you prefer it in audio or video
both are available as well as commercial
free audio and video streams of the show
and so much more it takes just mere
seconds just mere that seems actually I
don't need that it takes mere seconds
mere seconds at join pakman.com oh we
have a great place to discuss politics
with fellow viewers it is the david
pakman show subreddit at david
pakman.com slash read it that's our EDD
i.t about 21,000 if you can imagine
21,000 of our viewers and listeners are
subscribed free to the david pakman show
sub reddit users sneaky get posted that
white supremacist david duke has
endorsed tucker carlson as the vice
president you know david duke always
endorses someone and I hesitate to make
too much of it I know a lot in my
audience wanted me to talk about this
and point out this proves that he's a
white supremacist I'm pretty sure David
Duke endorsed tulsi gabbard um that
doesn't mean Tulsi is a white
supremacist David Duke always does this
and I think it's important not to I mean
you know Hitler breathe the oxygen right
that's the that that's where I go on
this and I wouldn't really make too much
of it obviously I agree that Tucker
Carlson has fed xenophobic and white
supremacist ideas on his program one of
his writers was recently fired for being
discovered to have been posting racist
things under a pseudonym on the internet
I'm not denying anything about what we
know about Tucker Carlson I just don't
think we should pay too much attention
to David Duke endorsing this person or
death or that person in a lot of ways
it's just David Duke trying to get
himself attention
user cremation
Lily posted a very interesting graph
that shows the correlation between
coronavirus cases and political leanings
and when you look at the data you very
clearly see that the places with the
most severe outbreaks now are
overwhelmingly what we would call red
states where as it is blue states that
are doing better right now now this is
going by governor now this is a little
tricky because Massachusetts for example
has a Republican governor who is one of
the more moderate Republicans in the
country and we have one of the most
left-wing legislators in the country so
to put massive massachusetts by all
measures really is a blue state but in
any case this gives us an idea that you
had the early hot spots when it came to
corona virus and those were really
related to places with early infections
mostly because of a lot of direct
flights to and from the prior hot spots
meaning China and places in Europe we
didn't really know what we were doing at
that point we're now five months in and
now what you're seeing is a divided
based on state policy and very clearly
the places that are doing better have a
certain set of policies at the state
level and the the graph certainly
confirms that and then lastly Stielow
fourteen posted an important question
about Donald Trump's urgent press
conference earlier this week asking has
the president ever called an urgent
previously unannounced press conference
to baselessly attack baselessly attack
his political opponent in a completely
incoherent manner for an hour straight
and then only take three questions one
question coming from right-wing
propaganda network Oh a and the answer
is no you know I didn't I didn't really
have to wrack my brain thinking no other
president has done that and we have a
press briefing scheduled for today which
I expect to be yet another just absolute
gong show and no what we're seeing is
unprecedented panic from Donald Trump
I'm losing give me a piece of paper with
criticisms of Biden let me go out there
and read it for an hour I'm losing let
me
place my campaign manager with only
three and a half months to go these are
signs of desperation and we've not seen
a lot of this before
join the discussion at david pakman.com
slash read it this is free I'm selling
you nothing it's just a place to discuss
the news and politics of the day with
other David Pakman show viewers and
listeners so now let me explain why
Donald Trump is panicking why he has
replaced this campaign manager with only
three and a half months to go before the
election five new election polls were
released yesterday and Joe Biden is
ahead by as little as three points in
the right leaning Rasmussen poll and by
as much as 15 points nationally in the
latest Quinnipiac University poll in
that same Quinnipiac poll Donald Trump's
approval has collapsed to 36 percent no
president has had a 36 percent approval
this close to their re-election election
day potential reelection election day
for a very very long time I think this
is actually worse than George HW Bush in
92 but I'd have to go back and look so
let's look at the new polling we got
yesterday just a ton of new polls five
general election polls NBC News Wall
Street Journal says Biden is up by 11
CNBC says Biden is up 10 Rasmussen as I
mentioned that's the right wing pollster
the best one for Trump has Biden up only
three Quinnipiac is the most insane one
which says Biden is winning by 15 and
then the Economist YouGov poll released
yesterday says Biden is up by nine you
also have some interesting state polls
one from this morning in Arizona says
Biden is up five in Arizona a North
Carolina poll from yesterday says Biden
is up one Florida poll says Biden up
seven which if Biden wins Florida by
seven you're looking at a historic
defeat for Donald Trump big if
big big big if in Pennsylvania Biden is
up eight and in Michigan Wisconsin and a
different Arizona poll Joe Biden is up
by six and then if you look at Texas we
saw one poll earlier this week that had
Biden up five in Texas the latest poll
out of
has Trump up too but understand that I
don't really think Texas is a place
Biden's going to win but Trump won Texas
by nine in 2016 if Trump only wins Texas
by two that is a major signal about
trouble for Donald Trump nationally so
let's pick one of these and look a
little more closely at it the Quinnipiac
poll not only does it have Joe Biden up
15 it has Trump approval at 36% with 60%
disapproving and the internals on
specific issues are important to look at
so let's put up on the screen and I'll
tell you what we're looking at here this
is the Quinnipiac poll key issues Trump
versus Biden on handling a crisis Biden
leads 57-38 by 19 points on handling
health care Biden leads 58 to 35 that's
23 points on coronavirus response Biden
leads 59 to 35 on addressing racial
inequality just brutal Biden ahead by 32
points and this is maybe the most
interesting one to me on handling the
economy Biden is now ahead of Trump 50
to 45 that's the most important factor
to me because we often have this
situation where Republicans are just
more trusted on the economy I discussed
with you last week how it's not really
borne out by the facts stock market does
better under Democratic presidents
unemployment is lower under Democratic
presidents on average recessions are
more likely under Republican presidents
inflation is lower under Democratic
presidents etc etc but the stereotype is
that Republicans are good for the
economy and for business even though
it's actually not true the fact that Joe
Biden now leads Trump by five on the
economy is massive because that was
essentially Trump's last stand so now
what we've got it right we can all just
kind of hang for the next four months no
no no no everyone must vote do not
become complacent even for a second we
don't have it Trump knows he's up
against the wall Trump knows that it
takes 8 to 10 weeks to flatten the curve
and that that's getting us dangerously
close to a
Election Day and that the cases are
still going up not down so he knows he
needs dirty tricks okay he knows he
needs deceptive online campaigns voter
suppression trying to hide coronavirus
data or data or both really so do not
become complacent even for a moment and
we'll have more coverage of this and
this latest polling on the David Pakman
show
Instagram page that's david pakman show
on instagram follow us there and he will
have much more for you right after this
short break the david pakman show at
david pakman.com
[Music]
the David Pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way is through
membership which includes the world's
famous bonus show as well as commercial
free audio and video streams of the show
just for members sign up today at join
pakman.com coupon code saves you 40%
vote soon 18 welcome back to the David
Pakman show it is great to welcome back
to the program today dr. Christopher
DeCarlo who's an award-winning
philosopher educator and author of this
the latest book on critical thinking
called so you think you can think tools
for having intelligent conversations and
getting along it's great to have you
back on good to be here always a
pleasure so a common question I get from
viewers when I take live calls is I have
family members who believe this or who
believe that and I want to know how it
is that I should confront them and
usually my answer is that depends on how
willing you are to ruin the relationship
in other words there there's ways to do
this more lightly with a Socratic method
of questioning and sort of gentle
inquiry into how one formed their
beliefs there's ways to have these
conversations much more pointedly and
aggressively it give me you're sort of
30,000 foot view on how some of these
often difficult conversations can be
approached right so in this book I talk
about spectral discussions and what I
mean by that is if an issue can be
polarized and many of them are you know
polarized
take for example gun control something
to which your country deals with on a
daily basis you know what you do is you
you look at the extremes of that what
what should we do well allow all guns
everywhere no matter what you can try
the tank to work you know you can do all
that kind of stuff the other end of the
spectrum no guns whatsoever you know all
that kind of thing and then start by
determining
on the spectrum the two discussants lie
like where are you and then see how how
you know polarized those views are and
then try to imagine is there any common
area between those two positions and
what are those so you know start with
what is your argument what is it that
you believe allow me to understand that
have each other say what their arguments
are back to each other it's that we call
a steel Manning you're probably familiar
with this yeah
rather than straw Manning the other
person's argument and making it a
mockery you really want to say okay so
let me get this straight
is this what you believe and then you
lay it on the line then they can do the
same now you you know where you are on
that spectrum and now you can talk about
you know would we be able to change our
views is there any evidence or any
information that might draw us closer
together so I'm finding that this method
is becoming very helpful yes Oh Peter
Boghossian has described that what would
cause you to change your mind if it were
the case the the feasibility test to see
if someone is even open to to
re-examining their their beliefs now
when it comes to I mean just to pick
something that has come up recently here
in the United State and by the way so
Christopher is Canadian and that's why
he said your country and just so people
understand the context here of the
discussion here in the United States
there's a big controversy now around
statues Confederate era statues and
statues reminiscent of slavery and one
of the critiques I had of a lot of the
conversations that are happening are
that the conversations in media are
often only represented by extreme views
meaning you should never take a statue
down and on the other hand take down
George Washington because he owns like
these extremes whereas most people
probably would be able to have a more
nuanced conversation like well listen
there was an era where everybody had
slaves and what we should look at is
maybe more whether the individual is
known for promoting slavery versus
whether they're really right so that
that's
seems to be a big part of the
conversation that often the
conversations are only happening in
extremes yeah and and it's unfortunate
right that and and the media is
partially to blame because they love the
extremes right you've got a great story
you get more clicks you get more hits
you get more viewers whatever it is you
know we were fascinated with the the
confrontation as it were we've lost the
capacity to appreciate nuance and it
looks like we're in a baby out with the
bathwater kind of movement right now
we're you know no matter what good a
person has done in their life if during
those times they were involved in other
types of activities which are now deemed
quite reprehensible or horrific or
horrible or you know whatever it is then
everything that that person might have
accomplished that was good is ignored
because they were involved with these
other you know kind of nefarious or or
questionable types of moral activities
and we need to have the conversation
around these statues to look at them and
say you know what good if any has has
this person done for Humanity and what
are the bad things and use it use these
as teachable moments and if if they if
they are indeed offensive for whatever
reasons should we just put them in
museums then and then use them as it for
educational purposes to say yes this
person did X Y & Z but you know what
they also did this as well you know I
teach at Ryerson University
Edgerton Ryerson was responsible for the
the school systems that put a lot of
Aboriginal kids took him away from their
parents and put him in these schools
what's called the residential school
problem but his statue is still standing
at Ryerson University and I'm wondering
if it's just a matter of time before you
know people will think you know that's
got to come down as well so he did a lot
of great things for education but he he
also did some not-so-great things it's
the world is more complicated if if we
hold our heroes you know those in high
esteem too high they have that much
farther to fall when we realized
nobody's perfect and and and you know we
are a nuanced difficult species at best
here in the United States
ates we are experiencing the deadly
repercussions I don't think that's an
exaggeration of a critical thinking gap
or lack when it comes to coronavirus and
this applies to understanding how masks
work this comes to you know ideas like
if we tested less we'd have fewer cases
I mean there's no shortage of sort of
examples what do you make of the way in
which this is failing in the United
States is it education is it culture is
its economics I mean like where do we
start yeah there are so many systems
involved here right and some of the work
I'm doing in critical thinking is
something I call relational systemics
which is to look at all the systems that
are involved that interplay and and
cause people to think the way they do at
a given time in history yeah we can look
at the education systems for sure but
you gotta understand you know
memes can kill you I mean I've written
about you know mimetic equilibrium and
the idea that when you get comfortable
with a set of ideas it doesn't matter if
they run counter to reality you know if
ideology can outweigh reality and in so
doing you mentioned it weaponized
ignorant you you talk about the idea
that the mask has become a symbol of
oppression in your country for some
people and that is absolutely bizarre
for the rest of the world to look at
that and think you're missing a really
important point here and that is this is
a public health issue it's not as it's a
political it has nothing to do with
politics we want everybody to survive we
don't care what your politics is we
don't want you to die we don't want you
to you know feel discomfort or to spread
the disease any further so you know that
is a horrific example of weaponizing
ignorance and using it as a tool or a
symbolic representation of a political
movement so some people in my audience
feel very strongly and I've even said
this before that if critical thinking
and epistemology and philosophy were a
part of everybody's schooling starting
probably around seventh-grade age 12
that a lot of this that we're seeing
be short-circuited and preempted
altogether but then I do get pushback
from people who maybe people who work in
school systems that are teaching these
things to some degree saying the problem
is bigger than that and you have to
understand that teachers can only do so
much anyway and a lot of it is what's
going on at home and what's going on in
culture and what's going on in the media
so what's the lowest hanging fruit where
do we start to turn this around and what
could have the best if the biggest
effect most quickly right
I've been lobbying governments here in
Canada and have had some success with
trying to get critical thinking taught
at the first of all at the high school
system you know very well David that
critical thinking teaches people how to
think right we it's the tools that allow
them to better understand information
and then to determine you know the
acceptability of that information and
whether or not they should act on that
information and I do very much believe
if we can get critical thinking into the
schools as early as possible I believe
seven and eight is probably the right
time to start to introduce it to get it
going I think would be much more
difficult for people to then say I don't
care what science says you know my
leader maintains X Y s because it
empowers people critical thinking isn't
just something you do it's what you live
and we have to make that a part of
people's lives so that it becomes almost
reflexive it almost becomes a reflex
action when information is is presented
in a particular way that is false to the
way in which the natural world actually
functions and that's where we need to
start we need to start at those those
middle aged grades you know seven and
eight and all the way through high
school for sure from from the standpoint
of the virus and what you've observed
what if we do a sort of analyses
analysis of fallacious thinking or
fallacious assertions what are the main
fallacies that you're seeing in the
context of discussions about cases viral
spread contagion treatment masks etc I
mean just get you know if you have a
couple bullet points on that
right well first of all it's the it's
the misinformation and disinformation we
have to stop and that's you know what
was at Wayne settle I can make itself
around the world you know halfway around
the world while the truth is putting its
shoes on or whatever
so once mince misinformation gets out
there we need to focus on how to combat
that quickly and effectively and to me
there's no easy solution for that social
media has gotten to the point where
influencers are being trusted more than
you know scientists yes and right once
we get to that level then I think it it
it becomes paramount that science and
the influencers if possible the
scientists and the influencers could
somehow work together right what's
horrifying about that is some attempts
were made like that for example doctor
foul she did a bunch of live streams
with folks like Stefan curry the NBA
basketball player and trying to sort of
bring it's just I don't know if it was
too little or too late but you've got
you know a political movement which is
listening more to a game show host than
an infectious disease doctor I know I
just don't know it's it just feels like
we're living in an alien's thought
experiment it just seems so weird what
what what's happening right to to see
this occur and to know what the truth is
and I'm not talking about big tree big
tea metaphysical truth or anything I'm
just talking about scientific
probabilistic truth that is for the
benefit of all humankind and I really
I'm at a loss with this one in terms of
what's the best way to engage in having
the conversation like how much evidence
can be provided in order to convince
somebody that they really ought to wear
a mask right that it it's not a
political statement that you know
finally Trump wore one for the first
time I think you know the other day what
was he a Walter Reed or wherever yeah
you know it was a they basically said
you're wearing one so that that's good
somebody's got to stand up to this
guy like I don't I don't know why people
aren't but maybe that's just that cult
of personality that he has right when it
comes to statistics it's of course we
know very much about how sticks can be
shaped in order to give a the impression
of a or the opposite of a and and a lot
of it is just understanding the
mechanisms that are used what
specifically can you recommend to the
audience in order to parse statistics
for themselves like when Donald Trump
says we're testing more than anyone or
the death rate has to come down tenfold
is this a mathematical understanding
that people need or is it more of a
critical thinking understanding both
like I really do think statistical and
probabilistic reasoning is a part of
critical thinking and it should be
taught fairly early on and I'm actually
dealing with teachers right now who have
who are you know creatively using the
pandemic to teach students about
statistics and probability it's a
wonderful teachable moment that they're
using under such hard you know
conditions it's it's you know it's like
that you know the flower emerging out of
you know the the manure kind of thing
it's wonderful to see them taking this
as a teachable moment that they can then
say look you know as I say this is a
numbers game this comes down to numbers
and the better numbers we have the more
accurate we can be with those numbers
testing tracing tracking knowing who has
it knowing who doesn't have it look
until there's a vaccine this is what
we've got this is our defense especially
with a virus that has a you know eight
such a large asymptomatic population and
that's really what we're dealing with
here and nobody really wants to address
that but the fact of the matter is we
can solve a lot of the issues if it's
done intelligently and if we have the
right numbers but we have to be together
on this in the United States if you look
at County data you see that the growth
rates of cases are significantly higher
in counties that voted for Donald Trump
relative to counties that voted for
Hillary Clinton but if we step back from
from that maybe so specifically in your
work have there been sir
groups that seem to do better when it
comes to critical thinking than worse
and I'm not talking about genetically or
anything like that but but through
cultural and education reasons whether
it's Democrats versus Republicans or
religious versus non-religious or
whatever the case may be are there
trends you've observed that's a great
question you know I mean we we have seen
that those who are more fervently
religious have a little bit more
difficult time reconciling
inconsistencies with their worldviews
but that's to be expected right you know
my my take on religion is basically you
know you can believe in anything you
want you just can't harm people through
those beliefs or harm other species
through those beliefs so if you're so
dogmatic you've reached a point where
you refuse to entertain the possibility
that you could be wrong you see the
obvious danger in that and and there's
when I look at someone like Donald Trump
there is nothing more dangerous than
blind ignorance which is not even
knowing you don't know like that's a
really dangerous epistemic state of mine
to be in and I see it continuously and
so yeah if a person is overly dogmatic
that's obviously gonna present barriers
right and then you have to adjust your
strategy for having a conversation with
that person you have to be much more
Socratic much more gentle in your
approach because the harder you try to
consider or analyze their beliefs the
more they're gonna dig in and say you're
the problem not me
what do you think will be the long-term
effect on society of of the virus I had
a conversation with a Brian Greene not
long ago and there there's sometimes
this instinct that this is really going
to change things period and the public
health is going to be done differently
the way people greet each other is going
to change permanently I tend to go in
the direction of things sort of return
to the mean and people go back to normal
and and it's very hard to get really
long lasting change for humans where are
you on that issue I'm hopeful you know
I'm cautiously
optimistic but let's face it David my
colleagues and I have been writing to
our politicians and to politicians in
China for you know over two decades
basically saying look there's going to
be a pandemic if we don't put
initiatives in place that monitor the
sale of certain types of species of
animals leave you it's just it was just
a ticking time bomb it was not a matter
of if but when and you know a lot of
them would come back and say what we
caught SARS you know we took care of
MERS we got h1n1 got a vaccine for h1
we're doing a good job and my colleagues
and I were saying yeah until we get
either a long incubation period or
people who are asymptomatic or both and
then you're not going to be ready and
they didn't listen to that so I'm very
hopeful that in the future we are able
to develop worldwide policies for other
countries in terms of how things are
done and this is not to you know
necessarily be you know critical of
other cultures for their lifestyles and
whatnot no this is really just a world
public health issue yeah these are just
facts just facts if bats and we know
bats contain a lot of viruses and they
do jump to other species which then can
jump to humans we need to take the
science and we need to utilize that as
best as we can to make sure this doesn't
happen again or if it does we've got
measures in place that will will stop it
clear very quickly and not allow this to
occur now that's hopeful for the future
in regards to your other questions I
think early on after people start to get
vaccinated it's gonna take a little
while for people to just start some
anyhow to handshake or to you know
congregate in groups or whatnot it's
it's gonna be interesting is it gonna
make a world of germaphobes I hope not I
want people to be germ aware we need to
be smart about pathogens and and and and
and I'm very hopeful that you're you're
in the Boston area where they filmed
jaws you're probably too young to
remember this but when jaws came out
there was a huge and
lakhs of students taking marine biology
right they were majoring in marine
biology when in you know Indiana Jones
came out there was a huge influx of
pious students taking archaeology I'm
hoping after this is a huge influx of
people going into microbial ecology
which is exactly what we need we need
people to understand the
interconnectedness of the very tiny
pathogens to the rest of the world it's
really an arms race between us and
pathogens and this was a virus a
relatively weak virus you know this was
I'm not gonna say easy but it could have
been much worse oh my goodness this
could have been you know imagine if this
were like an Ebola right it would be
horrific it would be you know black
death time it would be not a good time
for this planet yeah the book is so you
think you can think tools for having
intelligent conversations and getting
along we've been speaking with the
book's author dr. Christopher DeCarlo a
so great to have you on I appreciate
your time once again my pleasure
lab here the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners and
one way to keep us going is through
patreon where you can pledge as little
as one dollar per month or as much as
you want at patreon.com slash david
pakman show great perks and benefits as
well read about him the david pakman
show at david pakman.com
so it's Thursday and we do have new jobs
numbers another 1.3 million Americans
have filed first time unemployment
claims meaning last week remember this
week we learned the numbers from last
week another 1.3 million Americans have
lost their jobs are you becoming numb to
these numbers to some degree I mean I
want to remind you before the 15 week
weeks in a row of coronavirus job losses
the previous single day record for new
unemployment claims was about 700,000
we've had as many as 6 point 6 million
in one week and continue to have right
under 1.5 million per week for several
weeks now and the reason that this week
is particularly important is that today
we got the numbers from last week in the
last week we have seen states have to
sort of reshot down elements of the
economy that's happening this week
meaning next week and the week after are
going to be crucial weeks in seeing
whether these numbers start to go up
again the rate at which Americans have
been losing their jobs has been coming
down we're still seeing people lose jobs
but we had six point six million one
week and then 5 million 4 million etc
the rate has been coming down things are
reclosing though and the next two weeks
could be particularly ugly last week was
more of a normal week you might say as
normal as things can be during a
pandemic and 1.3 million more people
lost their jobs so that's now 15
straight weeks of job losses that's a
total of 51 million jobless claims since
coronavirus started now I know people
email me as if I'm trying to deceive I'm
I'm mentioning we don't have 51 million
people out of work right now so 51
million people at some point lost their
jobs during the last 15 weeks many
millions of those have either gone back
to work or found new jobs so of the 51
million only about 18 million remain
actively unemployed right now and that's
obviously far better than 51 million
although still historically high so now
the question is what happens next week
coronavirus has forced California to
reclose sectors of its
economy indoor dining is done movie
theaters a whole bunch of stuff that had
been open is now closing I won't give
you the full list of states but there
are many that are having to go backwards
in terms of opening even Texas is is
actually having to step back so this
week which will be reported next week
and also the following week are going to
be very very important now the other
thing that's upcoming and I want to
remind you about it is that on July 30th
we're going to get the first estimate of
second quarter GDP second quarter GDP
has been widely expected by both the
left and the right to be maybe the worst
economic corridor for the United States
possibly ever possibly at we might get
the worst GDP number in 14 days that we
have ever seen in the United States the
second quarter of course was April May
June at the end of June some stuff was
starting to reopen a lot of the opening
has happened in July so at the end of
this month we're going to get an
estimate of just how bad was second
quarter GDP I don't know how bad it's
going to be the expectation is that it's
going to be quite bad and sometimes when
you get a bad number that's slightly
better than what was expected it
actually feels like hey we actually got
off less seriously than then we might
have so I don't know what the answer is
going to be but in terms of the timing
July 30th we're going to get an estimate
of q2 GDP August 30th is when we'll get
a more fine-tuned number and that is
going to be very very close to the
election of either Joe Biden or Donald
Trump for another four years and this is
exactly as we've been predicting for a
couple of months cases going up q2 GDP
number is going to be dropped on top of
us sometime in the next two to six weeks
with different specificity and precision
as we get more accurate numbers by
August 30th we are going to have
dramatically more information than we
have right now about what the end of the
year in early 2021 is likely to to be
for the United States we may also have
some vaccine news
we may also have news about therapeutics
so in my mind I'm sorry you know I have
a question on Friday's show this week
about where do I believe the point of no
return is for Donald Trump in terms of
if he doesn't turn his polling around
and I'm going to make the case that it's
October 1st however I'm seeing September
1st as a date at which point we are
likely to have a lot of additional
important information about how things
are going economic data case data and
much much more
Donald Trump's daughter Ivanka Trump not
only made a fool out of herself holding
a can of Goa beans but appears to have
broken the same ethics rules and federal
law that Kellyanne Conway broke when she
previously promoted Ivanka Trump's
jewelry line and now Donald Trump is
also getting in on the action so let me
back up a little bit and explain the
entire thing to you now Goa foods
commonly just known as Goya
is an American company that sells food
products that are often in the Hispanic
foods aisle in grocery stores it's kind
of a weird name but not really the focus
of this segment but it's everything from
beans to frozen products flour coconut
can coconut sauces marinades etc that
Koya sells a lot of different things and
the company is owned by the UNA know a
family and they're the second richest
Spanish American family and by Spanish
now I'm talking about the country of
Spain they are a billionaire family from
from Spain the CEO Robert una Noah was
recently invited to the White House to
one of these propaganda events that
Donald Trump has been holding and the
Goya CEO said that Donald Trump is a
blessing for the United States that the
United States is blessed to have Donald
Trump as president and many people
including many Hispanic customers of
Goya products didn't like it and there
were calls for boycotts the normal
reaction outrage cycle took place Oh
everybody calling for a boycott is
suppressing the speech of Goya will this
Tuesday Ivanka Trump tweeted a picture
of herself holding a can of go
black beans with the message if it's
Goya it has to be good followed by a
Spanish translation csgo yeah the Innoko
said bueno or or as Argentinians would
say csgo Xie dno said 'we know so this
was just wacky she looks like a crazy
person the optics are bizarre and i
tweeted it out with the message
something is very wrong with this woman
but then it started to get more
interesting yesterday Donald Trump did
something similar posing with Goya
products in the White House including
what looked like a can of coconut
chocolate wafers beans and more and this
is a violation of federal law 5 CFR
26:35 dot 702 that's a mouthful it's
called use of public office for private
gain and it says an employee shall not
use his public office for his own
private gain for the endorsement of any
product/service or enterprise or for the
private gain of friends relatives or
persons with whom the employee is
affiliated in a none got non non non
governmental capacity this is the exact
same thing that Kellyanne Conway
violated when she suggested people go
out and buy Ivanka's jewelry in short
people in public office can't endorse
products in this way but that gets us to
the next level of insanity which is on
the one hand Ivanka's an advisor to
donald trump on the other hand she's not
supposed to work for Trump because of
anti-nepotism laws but on the other hand
they've gotten around this by making her
this kind of vague adviser rather than
somebody with a formal position which
she clearly would be barred from having
but she's still an administration
official of sorts but she's breaking the
law by promoting products but they can
go back to well she's really an
unofficial adviser it's a circle of
swamp it's a never-ending swamp that
gets deeper and deeper with every
passing week of this administration but
here's the deal I actually have an
optimistic message for you today I'm not
worried about this I know the
administration doesn't care
Trump's family doesn't care this is the
swamp filling corruption we were told
they were going to end we just have to
remove them in three and a half months
keep an eye on the bigger picture
rather than getting bogged down in
individual instances of swamp filling we
know they have to go evanka posing with
black beans doesn't change anything
yes of course it's illegal they're not
going to be any consequences
just vote them out just vote we have all
the information we need and we are
prepared to vote him out in November but
are we going to get enough turnout to do
it I hope we don't all have that
horrible feeling again on November 4th
that we had in November of 2016 I don't
want it and I'll be doing everything I
can to prevent it but you know don't try
try not to worry too much about yet
another law breaking action
we've just got to remove them otherwise
this will continue we have a great
voicemail number that number is two one
nine to david p and i have a new top
caller to play for you today this is a
caller who I don't really understand
their message there's an indescribable
janessa quad to this voicemail there
seems to be xylophone music playing in
the background it's an incredibly well
produced voicemail
I don't know what to make of it but I
absolutely love it take a listen to this
thank you ss especially with all the
representatives that are in anyway it's
great to hear your voice and I'm so
proud of the youth and all that has been
killed but anyway david packager yeah
you brought me for good
the fact of recognizing good television
and I'm proud of this presentation that
you represent and thank heaven for your
father and mother for bringing those
substantial intelligent gentlemen on
television
I'm LaRon Jensen I made a mistake before
when I was uh looking presentations on
how great you are
yeah I was thinking about you would be a
candidate for president well do for it
six-five oh whoa okay we don't wanna put
that with the we don't want to put out
their phone number of course I cannot be
president under the current law
because I was born in another country I
emigrated to the United States from
Argentina so I can never be President
unless the law is changed but I really
appreciate that the xylophone in the
background is a beautiful beautiful
touch I don't know if that's digitally
added or what's going on but thank you I
don't know that I have been called a
gentleman in any voicemail before
usually I'm called other things and it's
not quite so good we have a great bonus
show for you today Georgia Governor
Brian Kemp is banning mask mandates
banning mask mandates this will lead to
unnecessary deaths okay
period people will die who didn't have
to because Brian Kemp governor of
Georgia is saying cities cannot require
masks to be worn a California city has
moved to replace police with unarmed
civilians for certain types of traffic
stops it's a very interesting proposal
which we will discuss and lastly we now
are getting more and more data about the
rehiring that is going on in some
sectors of the economy and what we are
seeing small businesses do is yes rehire
staff but often at lower pay and often
at fewer hours according to a new survey
publicized by CNBC so we're going to
talk about that on the bonus show as
well remember you can get instant access
to the bonus show by becoming a member
at join pakman.com if you would like a
discount off of your membership give a
try to the coupon code July's surprise
all one word all lowercase July's
surprise I think will give you a nice
little surprise when you use that coupon
code on a new membership at join
pakman.com and remember as always you
can get the daily audio podcast for free
on whatever your favorite podcasting app
is if you are going back to work and
commuting and you want something to
listen to if you're biking around a very
safe coronavirus activity I'm listening
to podcasts when I bike around Boston of
course wearing a mask and the full thing
consider the david pakman show audio
podcast spotify itunes etc etc I'll see
you on the bonus show
thanks so much for watching today's a
full episode of the show just a reminder
today's sponsor is blinka the app that
lets you read or listen to an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try blink is for free and save 25%
off of a subscription when you go to
blink is comm slash David Pakman I've
also included the link right underneath
this video